very excited to have you join us
i am jack and i'm max we're brothers
what up we are the
creators of this thing called friday
beers which you may or you may not be
familiar with uh
and for those who aren't i think it's
helpful to give a little bit of an
explanation before i jump into this
thing jack
you're better at explaining it well
thank you
i still don't really get it let me let
me try to make sense of it
as best as i can friday beers is a
comedy universe
that max and i created end of 2019
uh on instagram november 2019 that's
right and
we started by creating what we call
found footage sketches and by the way
check out the instagram if you haven't
yet
that are made from friday.beers these
sketches are made of all of our favorite
tv shows
movies sports moments our favorite songs
and then we write
jokes on top of it and we create
characters on top of it and we tell
stories on top of these sketches and we
call them
live action memes yeah we haven't
trademarked that we probably should
get gary on that live action memes we
got
really big on instagram uh it was a
movement that we
like to say we saw coming but we never
did and it sort of became this
bigger community than we had ever
imagined the best way we've been
described in my opinion
is uh as zodiac signs
for your group of friends and that is
the single biggest reason that friday
beers became popular is
i think people saw their own friends and
this group of characters we created
and this show is dedicated uh to those
characters max and i
are the most thing that we're excited
about ever since coming up with friday
beers is how can we create a sketch show
so we were so psyched to team up with
all things comedy bill burr's company
ever heard of it we were lucky enough to
uh
dupe all things comedy into helping
produce this thing i don't think
bilber's even aware
this is being made no he's not yeah so
that's a show that we have for you and
that we've been
writing for you and getting comedians
and actors who are much funnier than we
are to star
and bring this podcast and these friday
beers characters to life
because at the core of what friday beers
is it's really not about two people
it's really about all of us it's about
everyone who follows the account
everybody who has a group of friends
that they can relate to that's why we
take voicemails on the show
everything that you guys send us and
share with us inspires us to write
sketches and put these characters into
funny everything you guys do informs
what we write about in that sense
everyone is listening is
is a co-writer who will not be credited
or you won't be credited or paid but
put on your resume you put it on your
resume you can say you are a colleague
of bill burrs
yeah without further ado we're going to
jump into welcome to friday we hope you
guys dig it we're going to have a new
episode for you
for the next 10 weeks of this summer
leave us voicemails tell us what to make
next uh
enjoy the wondrous world of friday beers
welcome to friday first voicemail
actually first ad freshly ever heard of
it
it's pretty fresh their chefs make you
meals delivered fresh
stop stressing about dinner go to
freshly.com friday for 40
off your first two orders that's
off your first two orders all right back
to the voicemails guys
logan i'm from uh british columbia
canada
and uh my question is what is the most
common thought that you guys have when
you're out on bender or
night out all right cheers
common thought you have during a bender
kind of
uh a contradictory question because
during a bender you're not thinking
it's just doing it fuels it just doing
it yeah so
that said though i think it merits
further study
it certainly does there's an art to it
that hasn't been explored
right uh but should be there are there
are people who are highly accredited and
respected
and uh empowered to speak other subjects
yeah and um i think that's if that was
something that was offered at my school
i'd be the first one to sign up for that
yeah if there was like a yeah like a
benderology 101
what if what if
all right settle down settle down please
take your seats welcome back
to benderology 101 the theory and
science behind
multiple day booze fueled body
annihilation
now please open your textbooks and crack
open the lukewarm keystone light on your
desks
we can commence our discussion of basic
philosophical concepts
pregame or post game that's essentially
a question of perception
renaissance drinkers argue that the post
game was merely a pre-game for the
morning's hair of the dog
while modernist theory maintains that
late night debauchery is the essential
foundation for self-punishment
amorphous frameworks indeed very good ms
wales
and per newton's laws of motion an
object at rest stays at rest
while an object on cocaine stays in
motion unless of course acted upon by a
benzo
or furiously masturbating until you fall
asleep 242 miss wales
at least one of you has been following
the required suck down curriculum
excuse me professor but isn't that a
reductive view given the evolving
interpretations of the more recent
consumption vortex theory
well mr pendergrast it looks like
someone's read ahead
cat who enlighten us well it's more
about recent case law
you don't have to look further than stu
reynolds v his meet to find precedent
here
it was ruled that the plaintiff's bender
was actually extended because his
attempt to masturbate
only fueled his insatiable horniness
prompting a 72-hour stay at the
moonlight bunny ranch in reno nevada
of course a groundbreaking case
the first in which a man has sued his
own penis in federal court
and won but professor that case is still
pending
his penis is appealing and countersuing
on grounds for habitual abuse oh that's
a pr stunt and you know it shut up it's
gonna get smacked down on appeal
these people face past clusters please
or you could have just smoked a doobie
excuse me sir we're in the middle of a
lecture here
lecture sounds more like a hissy fit is
that
so well in class it seems the janitor
feels inclined to partake in our
philosophical discussion
no it's just you're talking in here
about pre-games and post games
like it's your first time on a pong
table after reading the back cover of a
tucker max novel
speculating on what drives a man to
spend a long weekend at the bunny ranch
when
probably never even heard of backpage
before as a matter of fact i have
the chicks are so horny chicks are so
horny it's not even fair
you got that from wedding crashers
minute 97 chaz reinhold
were you going to plagiarize the whole
thing for us
yeah maybe i am a janitor but at least
i'm actually a degenerate
and meanwhile you just dropped 200 000
bucks on an education you could have got
bar hopping fast casual joints in fort
lauderdale last spring break
you don't know what you're talking about
i don't know what i'm talking about
if i asked you for a plug you'd probably
point me to an outlet
if i asked you about hangovers i bet
you'd start
quoting the whole movie sure it might
have been banged up once or twice but
you're talking about benders when you've
never been on one
you don't know what it's like to be
running for 98 hours straight
chewing the inside of your cheek right
at the two dollar blackjack table inside
a saratoga casino
because you need a few free drinks to
stop your hand from shaking
after spending your last blood stained
dollar bills on a taiwanese mma
undercard
meanwhile your wife said she's taking
the kids the last greyhound left two
hours ago
and you've got a loaded glock in your
waistband praying that this dealer bust
you're gonna put one through your
[ __ ] temple
good god man what the [ __ ]
it sounds like you got a real problem
i'm actually looking for the aaa meeting
i
i got a little lost and stumbled in here
and yes
room 205 next door ah appreciate it pal
cheers
sarah toga can bring even the mightiest
of men to their knees
hey you've reached the friday beer's
voicemail leave a message
simple question all-time favorite beer
to drink
on a friday thanks
might be simple but it's extremely large
and complex
a common misconception about us
is that we're like beer snobs or beer
aficionados and like
the fact is there's so many different
types of
beers that can do the right thing not
just on a friday but
in whatever mood that you're feeling
personally and this is this isn't even
intended to uh
to be parlayed into this sketch but i am
a big fan of mexican beers
that's just like me personally modelo
because it's it's a mood that says
there's no worries when you're drinking
a tecate or a medela or pacifico or a
corona i mean it's got
a bit more flavor than your t and you
can also i mean
i wouldn't recommend playing pong with a
model or a corona
but you could do it it's been done it's
possible yeah
underscoring the fact that whenever you
have a mexican
beer like that in your hand you do feel
like
you're checked out you're on vacation
and you can do
a little bit of an escape to somewhere
every time you get off work early a
corona gets its line
every time you see that cute girl from
apartment 3c at the bar
a corona gets its line hey so
uh can i buy you a drink every time she
rejects your advances and asks about
your wedding ring a corona gets its lime
how about you buy your wife a drink get
lost creep when you're sent to a shame
spiral that sends you on one of the
darkest benders of all time
oh yeah a few coroners are getting limed
and when you come to
three days later your kid's custody
hearing you might not be getting
visitation rights but a crisp cold
coronas
get in line your honor that is absurd on
what ground
please remain seated no i am not gonna
sit here and take this sit down
sir get your hands out but you fast
[Applause]
every time you're released from prison
after a six-month stint for assaulting a
bailiff
you guessed it a corona is getting lined
and when you walk into the closest bar
and start thinking about committing
another crime just so you can go back to
prison because it was comforting knowing
that in the clink at least you couldn't
possibly sink any lower
open wide it's lime time baby hey guy
what can i get you i'll take a corona
lime that sounds great
corona find your beach
dude you're looking really stressed and
tired lately i feel very stressed and
very tired i mean
are you trying to get in shape and eat
right by any chance that could help i
would love to
i think i have a solution for you
believe it or not it's freshly ever
heard of it it's
fresh it's oh so fresh freshly offers
chef made nutrient packed delicious
meals delivered
fresh to your door you'll never have to
cook it's making it easy to eat
better how does it work you visit
freshly.com and then you choose from
over 30 delicious satisfying meals like
steak peppercorn
sausage baked penne chicken pesto ball i
love to suck that chicken pesto
delicious freshly delicious and did i
hear right that it's only 6.16 per meal
that's correct and right now freshly is
offering our listeners 40
off your first two orders when you go to
freshly.com
friday dude i'm ready to stop stressing
about dinner and just go to freshly.com
friday for 40 off my first two orders
that's freshly.com
friday for 40 off your first two orders
oh thank you freshly it's so fresh
hey you've reached the friday beers
voicemail leave a message
hey guys uh my name is danny i live in
minnesota i'm currently in spain right
now for a triathlon
my question is why is
late night booty calls more acceptable
for women
booty calling men than it is for men
booty calling women what i'm asking
is i've had several female companions
text me late at night and of course i
respond immediately
however if i were to turn the tables and
text them
rarely am i met with an an enthusiastic
and or interested reply
uh thanks for the time bye
i need to know a little bit more about
triathlon dance i was gonna i was gonna
say
he started off with a roller coaster
from minnesota
in spain for a triathlon well maybe he
went to spain because uh he's sending so
many
late night horny texts that he was uh
intrigued by the
culture of dining late staying out late
when really is the appropriate time they
said
what did they invest like 10 billion
into getting a covered vaccine in a year
i think there should be that equivalent
amount of government-backed
spending to find a
um fda-regulated safe
um a safe treatment to regulate
horniness
i didn't have to run for help i didn't
have to call 9-1-1
and i didn't have to jerk off in the
shower while my girlfriend was sleeping
because you didn't get uncontrollably
horny again
it's important to take conversations
about chronic uncontrollable horniness
seriously
dehorn pills are the only horniness
reducer approved by the fda and in a
clinical trial
almost everyone taking dehorn pills were
found less likely to furiously
masturbate or make horrendous sexually
influenced decisions
almost i don't have to send dick pics to
every slovakian instagram model that i
follow anymore and i no longer spend
hours mining the girl on girl category
on xtube looking for the perfect
strap-on scene for me to achieve a body
numbing orgasm
next tube girl huh nice hey but
seriously do not stop taking d-horn
without talking to your doctor as this
may result in regrettable texts to your
ex ill-advised nudes off-color internet
search histories fbi investigations into
said search histories failed kickstarter
campaigns to restart backpage.com and in
rare cases the purchase of abyss
creations fully customized asa akira
realdoll that's 15k you cannot get back
even though you paid an additional fee
for full pubic hair and it showed up
bald which is [ __ ] [ __ ]
ask your doctor if you're holding enough
for dehorn or if you've done enough
pathetic things when horny to start
taking them
thanks to dhorn now i can stay away from
any erotic temptation
even the most perfect pair of feet
you've ever seen all 10 manicured toes
greased up and glimmering in the
sunlight
arch so high she's got be the dr schulz
girl
i'm sorry someone beating off
okay someone's definitely beating off
just finished the story man i'm almost
there
i mean the ad's almost over how high was
the arch oh god damn it guys
jerry's jacking off to the customer
testimonials again are you off your meds
no
i [ __ ] doubled my doses i am not no
this [ __ ] doesn't work i'm hornier than
ever all right guys guys i'm gonna need
some backup in here
hold him down hold him down dad go off
no you hold him down jesus i touched his
boner
just give me the syringe give it a stop
the syringe i don't need the syringe
please i'm sorry i'm just not the
surround hold still
damn it clear
right um i'll finish this one out uh
to learn more about if d horn is right
for you visit dhorn.com or contact your
doctor
d horn take back every moment
there we go cigarette
dude we made it through episode one yeah
one down nine to go
and hopefully many more after that for
everyone still listening thanks for
tuning in
you know that uh part snl after the last
sketch and they're all
on the stage and waving goodbye and like
everyone's hugging each other
and the music's going on that's this
part of the show
where we're going to say thank you for
listening say we hope to see you next
time
and play you out with an extraordinary
musical act that we have worked very
hard to bring you and this is
um performed by jackson bright who is a
friend of ours a very talented musician
go check out his other stuff which is
far far better than this one but
it's a fun little lick and a hasty
little like to hedge you out into the
weekend
we know what max and i hope is that
you're listening to welcome to friday
on a friday about to leave work and
about
to get into the mindset that you're
gonna need to get you through the next
three days
and hopefully the songs that we provide
you at the end of every episode
will be something that you can play to
slide
into the weekend this one's good for a
sunday morning too so sunday morning
re-listen to this as well thanks guys
for joining
see you next week
sunday morning i'm hungover
reading brutal texts i said
some lady gave me pink eye going
down was not the moon i went through a
back of my bow i think i butt checked
the butt like too
i woke up and i did not know what to do
[Music]
me
did i max that on my credit card oh yeah
yeah yeah it ain't the first time that i
did
but i called up the bank said it was
fraud and i don't think i
got a single one cell phone number
yeah but i know i fought a little kid
[ __ ] you and this pink i might be
worse than i initially assumed
cause i did not just get
[Music]
still wondering how i get out of the zoo
this will keep us nowhere to
be but somehow i
found this number and keith the one is
so
much neat
you